instead of like football or something
like that or boxing if the first games
they do is like tesh's castle and
everyone's on roids that would be
hilarious make it more like yeah there
there's space for this right like even
Tao will be like Papa how come you're
not as buff as The Rock and I'm like oh
I want to tell you the real answer but I
don't want to [__] ruin your [__]
hero it's
[Music]
steroids so a billionaire Peter teal
backs a doping friendly Olympics rival I
think that's tight it's about time dude
that's about so what is it going to be
called The Dope Olympics I don't know I
think uh the Olympics right now floating
term not official at all but like the
enhanced games that' be so sick isn't
that your dream like you always wanted
to see that yeah I think it's dope that
there's people that want to compete
clean but then also having seen people
on gear do stuff you're like but what's
the real human potential hop
top I want to see the shot put going in
the [__] stands dude I'm ready I want
to see cyborg they don't adjust the
stadium at all I want to see the cyborg
Olympics hell yeah so it's like the next
level you want to skip this already
isn't that like the Paralympics where
they're running with like different legs
no cuz they're disabled I'm not going to
dis faster remember they I'm going to
Super able them going to cut off their
legs and put robots they accuse them of
having unfair Advantage now yeah but
that's just the running one you don't
see the Downy dudes in the group being
like Oh no fair dude one day all sports
are going to be played by robots so I
can't
wait but they have to have a soul there
was a Genesis game that was like that
you know that that era of like Barry
Bond and Mark Maguire like did home runs
go way down after after they started
like testing and stuff they did go down
right I don't know home run counts cuz
the the biggest one that I understand is
in MMA and pride in the at the end of
the contract they right before you sign
it says we will not test for steroids so
you see all these monsters fight back in
Pride and then when UFC bought pride and
then those Fighters started coming to
the UFC you see everyone
deflate and you don't see these monsters
anymore so it would be cool to see like
what would a LeBron equivalent but also
on steroid what that [__] look like I
would make the argument that how come
Hollywood actors are allowed to but no
one else is true [__] Alan richon
speaking of that guy there's no way that
guy's not roed he claims he's not who's
Alan claims he's not Jack reachers the
new Prime show Jack reachers Alan
Iverson Alan richson Allan what Rich
yeah look up alen Iverson what is the
this guy what is the ethics behind using
performance enhancing like even steroids
all these these things or
drugs versus yeah like what's the what's
the argument what's the argument against
it is it like you're supposed to show
Human Excellence without any I think
when it's in a yeah competitive sport
atmosphere what's considered Fair yes so
there has to just be oh like all across
the board okay so if you got performing
Hing stuff and I'm just like all natural
then of course I'm going to be like wolf
I can't [__] throw it like this guy
or whatever you know what I mean plus
betting is also a heavy influence and
all this [__] so like imagine if um you
knew someone was roed out and [__] like
that you would probably place a beted on
them as more likely to be better at the
game than someone else oh odds yeah and
I think that's a big big part of it l
another big part of it I think is just
sponsorships I think that's a big thing
cuz where the money's coming from that's
all they care about so if like you know
weedies can't [__] say that this guy
just eats cereal Lance will never be on
a box again damn well I mean if that
becomes the standard you're going to
have a lot of kids juicing cuz they're
like well I want to be the top top well
you want how about just get a job at all
like look at Patrick Mahomes he's just
made like he's about to make like
[__] $400 million or some [__] like
that like that like those contracts are
so juicy isn't it worth it to like have
an edge on your competitors so you can
get drafted [__] like that yeah in the
fitness Community now there's hella kids
juicing cuz now there's a lot of
influencers that are young that are 19
I've been ju since I was 16 look at me
and you know we're in an immediate
gratification generation there's hella
kids are like 12 13 14 just jumping on
steroids but it is one of those things
kind of like what Jared was explaining
how there is a safe way to technically
do this right yeah but who's going to
[__] do the safe when they can do the
affordable or quick right yeah and the
mindset of inst uh instant gratification
people aren't trying to do it the safe
way but isn't I mean regardless if
there's a safe way isn't that like
saying there's a safe way to smoke some
cigarettes yes MH cuz you're still
smoking no matter what I imported drugs
I imported drugs from [__] India for
to get Accutane when I was like 30 just
to make sure just to clear my skin up
for the last time it sealed all my oil
glands and [__] but man I was down cuz
like going to a doctor and getting it
that way was way more expensive oh yeah
for sure you have to Dallas Buyers Club
this [__] so you had an Indian dude with
a trench Cod be like do you want to
Accutane better I went online and I
found a a spot that sent me
the you know it's the right it was risky
bro but I did my research on it heavily
before I bought it and then uh I found
enough people who were who who weren't
clearly weren't Bots who were real
people a lot of Asian people do the skin
whitening stuff that way too it's not
legal to to buy some of that [__] here
you want to be the white yeah wow cuz
they don't want to show that they work
in the fields you know wow yeah I think
I'm for the the league like that I think
that's [__] cool but then the
aftermath is scary because yeah there's
a moral dilemma to that right now you're
going to inspiring tons of Youth to
pretty much go and jump on steroids but
if they do this league and like half
those dudes [__] die that's not going
to inspire anybody to want to do a lot
of kids still do it isn't there isn't
there also like the the other side of
the edge of that sword though where
there might be a moral dilemma to that
but it's like live an average life until
you're like 65 70 or like hit Glory at
[__] 40 and maybe you'll die and be a
legend you'll be a legend you have [__]
tons of money of all the people that
died young we love them like if you die
sick then it's like well ultimately it's
your choice all the all the football
players that know that they're going
into this situation everybody's getting
concussions people are [__] it doesn't
stop other musicians from doing drugs
same with boxers you know what I mean
rockstars exactly it's like you know
that this is just a part of the cycle in
the culture but like you wouldd rather
still be a part of that than like
Average Joe for lack of a better name
look Tom Brady right he took a pay cut
to keep to so the Patriots could keep
adding skill players and [__] like that
and oh I think that paid off a little
bit like he he'll he's he's such a
legend now seven Super Bowls Fox is
paying him like half a billion dollars
basically to [__] do 10 years of
voice of of um commentary commentary
yeah so like because he forged his
legend that way took the pay cut then he
gets to cash in nonstop did he make an
Otani type of Deal or was the pay cut
like just an actual pay cut it was I
don't know I don't know how it's
structured but we know all those guys do
do everything though it's just they know
how they have a person to help them
clock in clock out all that [__] so when
they get tested nobody's natural Lance
Armstrong did that [__] like like an
expert like he had a whole system with
people and like and it's still C and at
the end of the day who are we but
[__] the average people who want to
be [__] entertained I like that we
can just spectate and you know what I'm
saying I would I would love to watch
it but I
also if we had the Japanese culture it'
be sick what do you mean cuz Japanese
culture they have Pride right no one
goes oh you see that [__] where
can I get some steroids they know it's
entertainment but in America
entertainment is life so when you see it
they're like ooh I need to go do this to
and but that's what makes America
America you know what I mean For Better
or For Worse that's just like that's our
[__] 13-year-olds with erectile
dysfunction and [__] but you're also on
the side that you're for this type of
league and and that's why I'm
conflicting What If instead of what if
in of you want the entertainment but you
don't want the the negative
effects if if they did instead of like
football or something like that or
boxing if the first games they do is
like tashi's castle and everyone's on
roids that'll be hilarious make it more
yeah there there's space for this like
even Tao will be like Papa how come
you're not as buff as The Rock and I'm
like oh I want to tell you the real
answer but I don't want to [__] ruin
your [__] hero it's steroids because
I do think that there is a difference
likeing these [__] up throwing
them in a ring to fight the [__] out of
each other you know what I mean verus
like he said we want to see aall get the
well that's cool
yeah there's there's high jump and then
there's [__] high jump there's like
long you know what I mean we're not even
thinking we're not we need to open our
minds a little bit imagine you're
watching like one of those true
Housewives shows and everyone's on roids
that's like the that would be an
incredible imagine watching Power slap
on roids
oh they already look like they are
though would it even be entertainment
everybody's knocking people out that' be
crazy dude not only are people getting
knocked out but hands are getting broken
dude we watching [__] Bowlers the
bowl doesn't even touch the the ball
touch the floor it's like who they have
to make it a quarter mile long [__]
Lane I would love to see a javelin toss
from like the whole rose on Ro all women
on roids 2 would be so entertaining to
watch let's be realistic or
those
so if a kid goes I want to be the best
[__] basketball player on planet
Earth but in order to do this I need to
start
now I need to take my supplements my
steroids whatever I'll be like all right
and you can't turn back though when you
[__] go actually I want to be a
scientist [__] no fool you said this
[__] at 12 years old or eight or
whatever the [__] I'm going to [__]
you're going to be sticking with this
till you die cuz you're all about
Freedom yep there is you know there's
such a funny thing about like that
idealism right like America is supposed
to be the land of opportunity and the
free which it is we were talking about
this yesterday too right you can come
here and you can have dreams just as
much as you can [__] fall in the pits
and get destroyed but that's also what
makes this [__] what it is right like
gambler's Paradise which is exactly why
I'm like also for something like this
like as much as there is that
D it's like well we're the land that
like allows it to happen just as much as
it allows you to see that there's a
moral dilemma so it's your choice you're
like that wasn't a great idea guys it's
not like let's hide the moral dilemma
about it so we can just be entertained
it's like it's clear we'll make movies
and documentaries about how it's going
to [__] people up and you can watch it
when you subscribe to Netflix what's the
best roided sports then out of all the
sports the best roided sport
synchronized swimming out what's the
best ones
swimm arm wrestling they ripping each
other's arms off clean out of the socket
I say basketball yeah Roy then everybody
can dunk that'd be cool cuz everyone can
jump back or you could just lower the
rim for
WNBA you got to lower for them and give
Moon Shoes what's that um what was that
one Korean physical 100 yeah I was just
thinking about so that was a good
example because the most roed out
[__] didn't win yeah the guy
that everyone said was you yeah there's
so much to athleticism there's like your
IQ your like your
coordination yeah there's so much like
survivors the fact that the ice climber
guy got way farther than like roided up
dudes what is the main thing that like
people who take roids like actually get
they want to be sexy it depends so
there's endurance roids there's strength
roids there's uh muscle roids there's
recovery roids then there should be like
literally categories for those things
tear it off would you want to see combat
in roided out dudes secretly yes like
like Pride MMA like that no but like
Gladiators with like giant Q-tips I want
it's so oh yeah cuz even in uh like the
reason why ader the reason why Aderall
is illegal in the Olympics is it
increases your reaction time wa reaction
time and hand ey coordination so there's
other like when we think about roids
we're thinking about anabolic steroids
there's a lot of different types of PEDs
right so performance enhancing drug
someone is is throwing a dart like maybe
the the thing to make them better Dart
thrower isn't bigger muscles it could be
Aderall where he can like or he or she
could zoom in into the Bull's Eye like
way more let alone it UPS your training
regime because you're able to like hella
focus and train for long what if a new
game is created because of that cuz then
right now what if the human like cap is
here but with roids and being a cyborg
and everything else there's new games
that can be played that's what this is
right I think it's about taking just the
regular games and then having people
just do Dr I think that's a part of it
but I think that if if there's like a
particular type of drug that enhances
you for a particular thing what's the
[__] human highest achievement of
that thing okay dud what you a 100 yard
field goal you never even have to have
the quarterback get on field that' be so
crazy that would be insane your
quarterback's just on the bench the
kickers are the highest they would just
make a giant bigger field then you
wouldd have to train to like reel it
back cuz that shit's going way too far
way too far yeah you You' make a bigger
field or the ball would be a bowling
ball cuz the record is 65
yard who has that record um [__] his
name [__] his name [__] what his name is
that's sick 65 yards God damn Roy's in
video
games oh well that will just make you
infinitely yeah but it like goes goes
back to like the specific type
of yeah Focus those [__] will
just start dying again like the
Counter-Strike era where they just
played until they died dude that'd be
sick if they had a Roid Rage like uh
point system too like if how mad you got
they're like oh he's killing it look how
pissed he is look why he's about to lose
in 4
3 ladies and gentlemen no one has ever
been this pissed all the judges have
been people that were high experien Roid
Rage yeah that' be
sick
[Music]